foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday January 31st I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
it's been a rough year for meta the
parent company of Facebook Instagram and
WhatsApp there's been increased
competition it faced blowback from users
when Instagram made changes to its
format and Apple's privacy changes have
hit its ad business just to name a few
but the tide may be turning for the
company as it uses artificial
intelligence to Crunch data it has and
improve some of its struggling features
that's according to internal documents
reviewed by The Wall Street Journal and
interviews with people familiar with the
matter with me to discuss how meta is
using Ai and where it's making a
difference in its operations is our
social media reporter Salvador Rodriguez
hi Sal thanks for joining me thanks so
much for having me
what areas meta has turned to AI for
well So Meta uses AI all across the
company but in the last year they made
it a priority in two specific parts and
that's in improving the reels that are
shown to users in their Instagram and
Facebook feeds as well as using AI to
better draw predictions for what type of
ads to show to specific users so finding
deeper correlations from the data that
they have from their own systems than
they could previously okay so let's
break those two things out starting with
reels how exactly is AI helping meta
here in the last couple of years they've
seen The upstart Tick Tock rise up and
whenever you see a tick tock their AI
their machine learning technology it's
doing a really good job getting a sense
of what you like and then showing you
more of that and that's really good for
optimizing and maximizing how much time
a user spends on that
and So Meta really had to level up and
get to a point where they can rival
Tick-Tock in the sense of creating that
type of flywheel where they're showing
you the right kind of reels and they're
learning from you which kind of reels to
keep showing you moving forward
since Apple's privacy changes how is
meta using AI in this area
when Apple made these privacy changes it
really reduced how much meta could rely
on data from outside of their apps and
services to determine which ads to show
to which people and how effective Those
ads were and so one technique that the
company has turned to to make up for
that loss of Revenue and that loss of
data signal is they're using more AI to
draw deeper correlations from the data
that they already have so basically
using more technology to better
understand their users without actually
collecting more data from them and so
this is something that the company has
really bet on that's what my sources
have told me and it's something that
they've been working on over the past
year they've seen progress and they hope
to get to a point where they can make up
for most of that loss of signal that
occurred because of Apple we know this
from internal documents posted within
the company hearing about town halls at
the company and our own sources who have
been at the company who have been part
of this work familiar with this work and
just a combination of all that letting
us know what the company's strategy is
for overcoming these two big challenges
just to be clear the AI that meta is
using it's not the generative AI like
chat GPT uses and that we've been
hearing a lot about lately right that's
right it's very different than that AI
comes in many shapes and forms and in
this case it's basically meta having to
improve their own systems that just get
a better sense of what their users are
doing and how to better serve those
users so it is AI but it's not the same
type of AI as is in Vogue at the moment
you know this other area that they've
been struggling with has been the
metaverse we've talked about it before
on the show they made this big pivot CEO
Mark Zuckerberg said they were going to
be a metaverse first company but where
do things stand with that effort well
the last that we checked in regards to
the metaverse the company was not doing
great they've made Horizon the key part
of their metaverse push and from some of
the reporting that we did late in 2022
we saw that they've actually lost users
since launching and that's never good
especially for a service that is so new
I'm eager to find out how it's done
since then and of course you know
whether there was any Boost from the
holiday sales period when typically more
people go out and buy new Quest headsets
so we'll have to see if there's been any
Improvement on that front but based on
analyst estimates for their upcoming
quarterly results you know analysts are
actually expecting that revenue for
reality Labs which is meta's division
that works on all these things will
actually be down almost 19 compared to a
year prior so the expectations aren't
really high on that front all right
that's our reporter Salvador Rodriguez
thanks for joining us Sal thank you for
having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]